Is this real life?
Yeah, this is real life.
Le jour de tes 25 ans, tout le monde te dit la même phrase :
«Alors, un quart de siècle !»
Quand les gens, ils disent «un quart de siècle», direct, tu penses à un truc.
C'est le p'tit graphique de la vie.
Sauf que, dans le quatrième quart, bah, t'es.. T'es mort, en fait.
Dans le troisième quart, t'es à la retraite.
Ou alors, tu regardes des chiffres et des lettres.
Donc finalement, à 25 ans,
Il ne te reste plus que la moitié de ta vie active.
Pour oublier, je vais partir un petit peu en vacances pendant une semaine
Je vais prendre le train
De toutes façons, la SNCF, j'ai la carte 12-25
Donc, euh..
Ah, bah non!
Ah, bah non, du coup, je ne l'ai plus!
Ah, parfait.
À 25 ans, t'as de plus en plus de potes qui veulent faire des soirées entre couples.
De soirées entre couples...
Y'a pas plus raciste que le concept des soirées entre couples!
Ouais, ce soir, on se fait un p'tite soirée-couples avec Fred et Caro?
Ah, il y a une soirée ce soir? Je peux venir?
Bah, non! Toi, t'es pas en couple!
Toi, ta vie, c'est de la merde!
Donc tu vas rentrer chez-toi, ce soir, tout seul, tu vas manger des pâtes et tu vas regarder Secret Story!
Le mec, il est célibataire et il veut venir à notre soirée! Mais, pour qui il se prend? C'est genial! Trouve-toi une copine, je sais pas, achète-toi une gueule!
À 25 ans, tu manges plus trop sucré, tu préfères le salé.
Tes goûts changent.
J'prends mon café sans sucre.
Ah, serveur! Je vais prendre un café noir, s'il vous plaît.
Court, serré. Puissant, sans sucre.
Sans tasse, et sans café, s'il vous plaît.
Merci! C'est nickel.
Oui, oui. Non, j'adore la bretagne, ouais.
Bah, j'ai déjâ pêché, euh..
Quelques truites, là-bas.
Et même des fois au resto, quand le serveur me propose la carte des desserts,
Je réponds :
J'ai prendre, euh, le fromage, s'il vous plaît.
Sans sucre.
Maintenant, j'aime bien le chocolat noir,
Pas mal.
Mhm.
C'est bon le chocolat noir.
Faux!
Avant, quand je faisais des soirées entre potes,
La table basse du salon,
Elle ressemblait à ça :
Maintenant, elle ressemble à ça :
Oh, vous partez en bretagne! La bretagne, c'est magnifique!
Attends, les crêpes,
Les crêpes.
La table basse des gens matures.
À 25 ans, ton corps commence à grossir.
Tu prends concience qu'il faudrait peut-être que tu commences à faire du sport, en fait.
Alors, j'ai acheté un tapis de gym.
Je l'ai déplié,
Puis, je l'ai rangé dans mon placard,
Puis, en fait, je n'ai jamais fait de sport
À 25 ans, tu commences à avoir des potes qui ont déjà des enfants
Et, quand ils te montre leur enfant en photo,
T'es obligé d'avoir cette réaction
Ça, regarde. Ça, c'est mon gamin. Il a 2 ans.
Oh, le petit bout de chou comment il est trop mignion!
Oh!
Rah, il est à croquer!
C'est carrément hypocrite. Tu vas jamais avoir une réaction sincère!
Et ça, c'est mon gamin.
Il a deux ans.
Ah, non.
Ah non, j'aime pas.
J'aime pas trop son style.
Je..
Non.
Parfois même, je commence à dire des phrases de vieux.
Ah, c'est mon époque, ça!
Enfin.
Ah, j'écoutais, pas, hein?
Je connais, quoi.
J'écoutais pas ça, moi.
Moi, j'écoutais Korn.
Quand je vois certains de mes potes sure Facebook, qui ond déjà un femme, qui sont mariés, qui ont un enfant,
Je me dis qu'on a pas tous 25 ans de la même façon, en fait.
S'tu veux, depuis, on s'est installé, hein, donc euh..
J'ai fait un p'tit prêt à la banque et je me suis acheté une Clio Sport.
Euh..
Tout se passe très, très bien.
Et toi, tu deviens quoi?
Euh.. Bien, moi, j'essaie de passer mon permis
Sinon, je..
Je cherche un stage,
Bolosse!
D'ailleurs, en parlant de stage, hier, j'ai reçun un mail d'un mec,
Qui voudrait faire un stage avec moi.
J'sais pas trop ou est le délire,
Parce que..
Moi, je fais mes petites vidéos tout seul
Je vois pas ce que je pourrais faire avec un stagiaire.
Salut, Norman!
Je suis ton nouveau stagiaire!
Alors, par quoi on commence?
Euh.. Bah, je sais pas.. Si tu veux, euh.
Si tu veux, on peut aller faire les courses?
C'est de la merde!
J'me casse.
Il faut que j'arrête de m'habiller comme un gamin.
Mon chat Sergi, lui il s'en fout, il s'habille comme il veut.
Abonne-toi à ma chaine Youtube
En cliquant ici.
Et tente ta chance pour peut-être gagner
Un pinz!